hello Jim thank you thank you Tara
good evening everybody and welcome to
this District planning committee held on
Wednesday the 6th of September 2023. my
name is councilor Kevin Lagan and I am
the chairman of this committee
members and visitors please due to the
climatic conditions I.E it's hot please
feel free to remove any out of garments
tires or anything that makes you feel
more comfortable wouldn't it with
indecency and I'm also suspending rule
for subsection 8 subsection 3 to um the
need to to stand when speaking unless
you feel that you wish to
so thank you this evening I'm joined by
officers Mr Michael Johnson head of
service development management Simon
quelts lead legal specialist and
monitoring officer and Devin herner
development management specialist the
meeting will be clocked by Mrs bird
remotely members and all present and
those people in the gallery are welcome
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you're giving your
consent to being recorded during each
item please put your hand up to indicate
if you wish to speak I will then invite
you at the appropriate time obviously
there's just myself this evening so
please be patient and I will capture
everybody and I will give everybody the
opportunity to contribute accordingly
um could I ask members to take care of
approaching the main bench as this could
create interference with the cameras and
the live stream and please note that the
YouTube live stream sound recording is
dependent on the correct use of
microphones therefore can I ask you if
I'm invited to speak you remember to
turn on your microphone and turn it off
when finished please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible as always please
thank you so we move on to a gender item
two which is apologies for absence Tara
may have the apologies for absence
please
thank you very much indeed Tara
agenda item 3 which is the minutes of
the last meeting is recommended the
minutes of the meeting held on 11th of
July 2023 which are found on pages 7 to
18 are approved as a true and accurate
record ISO moved do I have a second to
please
councilor Jennings thank you very much
indeed
they're no two guitar Declarations of
interest at the section 4 is to disclose
the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
registerable interests and
non-registerable interests relating to
items of business on the agenda have in
regard to paragraph 9 and appendix B of
the code of conduct for members members
are also reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as become unaware should the
knees arise throughout the meeting
do we have any uh declarations this
evening members please
no that's lovely thank you very much
indeed members we move on to item five
which is reference two three zero zero
zero seven six slash f-u-l which is land
north of West riversley nips was Chase
Mayland which is found on pages 19 to 58
of the agenda pack members there was an
update issued with regards to this
matter
the officer presenting the application
will be Miss herner in a moment and we
do have three public speakers registered
to speak
okay every member of the public and
those registered will have a maximum of
two minutes following the officer's
report okay thank you Miss herner
thank you chairman
before I begin with the presentation
there are a couple of verbal updates
that I need to make members aware of so
since the members update was published
yesterday we have received some
additional letters of support which
takes the total of letters of support to
um 14 as at the close of business today
the additional letters of representation
mainly repeat repeat the previous
representations have been made and do
not have a material impact on the
officer's assessment the letters largely
relate to the support for Rural
businesses and suggests that the
building is too small however there's
been no evidence of any sales of produce
from the site and this proposal would
result in a loss of an agricultural unit
not a game
further there have been no applications
to expand the building and no evidence
that the stable and store approved to
the north of the site which was not
under construction during a site visit
undertaken last week would be capable of
accommodating agricultural need
also as will be set out in my
presentation these matters are not
relevant to the consideration of the
application at this stage
I would also advise members that the
quantity of letters either in support or
against an application is not relevant
it is the quality of the submissions
that are relevant in relation in
relations of relevance and importance of
the planning considerations that they
raised
as advised in paragraphs 1.1 and 10.1 of
the addendance of the committee report
officers were advised at legal advice
from the applicants Barrister would be
received on the 10th or 11th of July
2023. this was part of the reason that
the application was deferred from the
previous District planning committee
officers requested this advice prior to
the 14th of August to ensure there was
appropriate time to consider its content
the legal advice was received yesterday
the legal advice sets out the planning
history of the site as well as matters
that have previously been raised by the
applicant and addressed Independence one
of the officer's report
the Barrister's submission suggests they
do not agree that the case law in the
officers report sage and William are
relevant yet there has been little case
put forward as to why
the Barrister relies on the internal
fixtures and fittings after the remedial
Works have taken place to suggest that
the day-to-day domestic living could not
occur in the building and as such it is
not a dwelling
however the remedial works are
Irrelevant in this case and it's clear
that the building as essentially
coupling could have been used for
comfortable day-to-day living
the Barrister's advice was dated the
10th of July and therefore suggests that
the enforcement notice it had not yet
taken effect the notice took effect on
the 27th of July and so this comment is
no longer applicable
overall the Barrister's comments do not
raise any matters that would result in
offices reaching a different conclusion
to that which is set out in the report
so that brings me on to the presentation
this is a full planning application
submitted for the change of views from
an agricultural building to a
two-bedroom Bungalow as well as an
alterations to the fenestration
The Works other than the additional
Windows have already been completed and
evidence suggests that the internal
Arrangement was constructed in a manner
set out in the plans from the outset
the application site gained planning
permission for the erection of an Apple
store in August 2020.
however the evidence submitted with the
application as well as other evidence
available to the council such as
building control records demonstrate
that the building was not erected as an
agricultural building but as a dwelling
therefore the building was constructed
without planning permission
members will be aware that the
assessment contained from the report
considers whether the development is a
change of use rather than planning
merits over dwelling the assessment is
based on that because the building was
not erected as Agricultural and so a
change of views can not lawfully be
granted
it's important to stress this point is
effectively what it could mean for
decision making is if someone can apply
to obtain planning permission for one
form of development building something
else itself needs permission but seek to
rely on the permission granted to
exercise a change of use from an
approved scheme that was never
implemented to not apply for a change of
use so far
is to apply retrospectively for a
development that was never approved is
an emission that unauthorized
development had been carried out
contrary to the council's own
development plan
I will set out the application and as to
why this conclusion was rich however
before I go into these matters as
members are already aware an enforcement
notice has been served on the land for a
planning breach consisting of the
unlawful construction of a dwelling
house therefore on the base on this
basis it is the councils not just
officers position that the building is a
dwelling
so here we have the location plan
looks like it's just taken off of
nipsel's Chase
the bullet plan
the elevations are proposed so there's
an additional window here and a window
here that hasn't yet been constructed
this is the approved elevations of the
Apple Store
the proposed floor plans
and the previously approved floor plans
so here we have some site photos of the
site entrance and the access track
and just highlighting that there's
postal books but no lawful dwelling
currently on the site
some photographs of the exterior of the
building
photos of the interior of the building
so these were taken in place prior to
the remedial Works outlined in the
members update that was taken to the
Southeastern area planning committee the
red lines I've put on the plans there
are just to try and show
um where these walls
um were actually constructed in relation
to the Apple Store plans
so you can see there's some um
residential elements in here coffee
table sofa
um sort of the finishes that you would
expect to see in a residential property
rather than an agricultural unit such as
the plastered walls the the door frames
so in
um this room should be the Apple Store
uh these three rooms sorry which should
just be an Apple store and implement
store we do have some agricultural
equipment but it's been stored on um
cardboard in what seems an attempt to
protect wooden flooring which isn't
deemed a convenient
um solution for an Agricultural use
again we've got plastic ceilings and
walls
um skirting boards window seals
we've also been advised at residential
style installation has been included
we was first told that this was to keep
apples at the right temperature
um which set out in the officers report
only need to be up to seven degrees and
it's now been expressed that this is due
to the applicant's needs
we've also received country
contradictory information in relation to
the subdivision of the rooms which was
initially said to be due to fruit fly
issue but this has recently been said to
be a result of Parish Council comments
so here we have a fully equipped Kitchen
in the implement store it's considered
that this would take up a lot of room
um that would be much needed space even
an agricultural unit and you wouldn't
expect to see things like display units
in an agricultural working kitchen
and this is a hallway which wouldn't
um be functionable as an agricultural
unit in order to you know it's quite
narrow to bring things along and this is
a store room the applicant distance
clarified that the labels on these boxes
are um relate to molds for sweets
so these are photos after the remedial
works but just to reiterate that
we're assessing the application at the
building as it was at the time the
application was submitted remedial Works
can't revert and um
bring their permission back into
into use
um there we go so this still regardless
there's still some Romanian residential
features and fittings door the doors
that you can see
um here like fittings window seals and
so on
there's still um some wooden flooring in
part
and yeah see similar there
so the first consideration must be
whether the development constitutes a
change of use in order to address this
the council must determine as a matter
of fact and degree whether the building
as erected constitutes an apple storage
barn as allowed under the original
permission
there are two pieces of case law that
are pivotal in this assessment and have
been placed on the slide
the assessment in the officers report
against the relevant case law and based
on the evidence before the council
concludes that the building as
constructed was not an apple storage
barn
on the basis of the case law the
development does not fall under a change
of use the council could not reasonably
approve an application for a permission
for a change of use of a building where
the construction of the building itself
is unauthorized this would be legally
improper and could be the subject of
judicial review
given that the application could not
reasonably granted on the basis of the
application that's been submitted an
assessment considering the suitability
of a change use that the site has not
been outlined in the officer's report
the conclusion from officers and the
legal officer is that the application
cannot be approved and that there is
nothing that could justify this as a
change of use application
the dwelling was not built with plan
information a stance taken by the
council in an issuing an enforcement
notice and this is not an application
for retrospective planning permission it
is an application for a change of use
for a building that has no permission
therefore the application is recommended
for refusal thank you chairman thank you
Cerner Mr Grouch would you like to speak
now or after the public speakers
yeah I don't I don't think Chairman's
anything for me to say at the moment
because I don't know what's in members
Minds what advice they need whether they
understand the case law or not
um so maybe members understand the case
law and therefore I don't need to say
anything okay we'll move ahead thank you
Mr Welch that's why you're here
um so we have the three Pub counselors
Luke oh my apologies for councilor fluka
thank you chairman um coming up there's
been some rather in my work German well
the ghastly emails circulating which
have included me uh regarding this plan
application and one of them evolved
around the reason why I proposed
um deferring this matter to the district
planning committee and the principal
reason for that was was at the southeast
area planning committee meeting we seem
to have a conflict of of legal opinion
that was given by officers and by the
applicants Barrister
um part of that legal advice was based
around a case called quick fit uh case
law regarding the quick fit case
um which the council at the southeast
area planning committee seemed to rely
on heavily but I note that it's no
longer uh being mentioned I I once I
wondered chairman whether or not Mr
quelch
um could confirm that he's no longer
relying on that piece of case law which
was presented the southeast area
planning committee
thank you chairman thank you Mr
President now that's the start and
there'll be no more questions until
public speaking thank you yeah um I mean
that's absolutely right what council
fluke has said the quick fit case was
relied on by The District Council
officers
um uh the quick the quick fit case
really quick safe case sorry
um
it was really dealing with the issue of
whether use of a building was de minimis
or not
now in this particular case
um my view is and going back to our
Council our Barrister actually that's
really not necessary to go down that
route in this case
we can simplify it the simple issue
really here is the council have already
made a decision
um by taking enforcement action
um that this building wasn't built
as per the planning permission 2020 as
an agricultural storage bomb was
actually built as a house and therefore
is an unauthorized building if it's an
unauthorized building it follows you
can't apply for a change of use
to a building that legally in planning
terms doesn't exist
now because enforcement notice has
already been served albeit that is the
subject of an appeal
by the by the applicants and that will
obviously go before an inspector
sometime in the future
to see whether the council got it right
or not
um the fact of the matter is that the
decision to issue an enforcement that is
a council decision it's as much a
council decision as any decision that
members would make here has the same
status in law so their Council has
already made a decision that this is an
unauthorized dwelling so you cannot
effectively Grant a change of use
of a building that is unlawful if you
see what I mean
and that's why the quick fit so the
quick save case is not
um relevant because whether there's been
de minimis use or significant use
it it doesn't Advance the case any
further
if that makes sense
okay thank you Mr Crouch
um we'll move on we'll now invite the
public participation we have three
um public participants speakers whoever
supporter Parish Council representative
and an agent and the first person is a
supporter Mrs Dyer McBean you're
attended in person Diane so if you'd
like to make your way forward to the
Horseshoe please and probably come to
this area next to councilor Thompson
oh you're going to squeeze over thank
you counselor stem thank you not as long
as it's comfortable
so
it was then however you feel more
comfortable
um councilor Stanford Council still to
make sure that they either microphones
turned on to help you
um just to point out that you have two
minutes you see the timer on on the
screen
so you have two minutes which will start
counting down from the moment you start
talking so when you're ready and
composed feel free and we'll start
my name is Diane and I speak and support
my brother Kenny's planning application
as our entire family is extremely
worried about the impact these recent
issues have had on both Kelly and Sue's
Health in 2015 Kenny bought scrubland
and transformed it into the beautiful
Orchard a nature friendly place that it
is now he obtained permission to build
an Agriculture and office building using
an attractive unobtrusive local design
approved by MDC construction complied
with all guidelines planning permission
and building regulations and MDC
Representatives visited and approved at
every stage of building
the permission has a large office Kenny
works there three days a week all year
round and is of course insulated and
heated to enable summer and winter use
they started planting the orchard in
2016 and my family have all helped with
it and planted our own trees it is a
huge amount of work for them not just at
harvesting and juicing but all year
round with pruning Pest Control mowing
winter washes and all equipment needs
stored in the building it is not the
Minimus use the orchard is Kenny's pride
and joy and has increased 30 percent
since building the Apple Store it is a
growing Enterprise and now needs a
bigger building
Kenny applied for grant funding with
support from retailers but didn't
succeed if he had got the funding he
would not need this change of use
application to fund the growth
the Machinery alone will cost 140 000
pounds and the same again to insulate
and finish the large barn that is on
site
mdcc say it was also dwelling it has
never been used as such if that had been
their intention it would have been built
with blocks and not cheap timber frame
which is difficult to mortgage
his Barrister says there is no legal
reason to refuse the application and the
case law mentions completely irrelevant
cases Kenny has done nothing illegal
here in MDC now except nobody has ever
lived in the property
MTC now insists that this beautiful
building must be demolished this is
planning not politics please approve the
application
thank you very much indeed green thank
you
Now call upon Parish representative
councilor Debbie down Debbie can you
hear us
hello yes okay okay Debbie I don't know
if you heard it earlier on but if you
have two minutes to speak um starting
with the first time you speak
um and the clock will start to commence
downwards thank you when you're ready
thank you the original planning
application 18 stroke double zero two
eight zero was for an actual Storage
Barn at land Northwest registry may have
had Parish Council refused recommended
reviews on The Following grounds
materials for Apple cracked area not
suitable for drink production wash down
the prep area would be required of this
space open to spread area only one
entrance to store and prepare no there's
a fire escape for staff
cross-contamination of fruits and nuts
material flow crosses path several times
no ventilation in store obvious and prep
area layout of prep equipment not
defined since sanitation Etc fermented
vessel size is totally inadequate such a
small building could not affect the
sustainability of solid production from
inflow given basically the design was
wholly unsuited for this state of
purpose despite these objections more
than District Council will prove this
application with conditions to be
adhered to new application is 23 stroke
zero seven sixes for the change of use
from agricultural to a two-bedroom
Bungalow C3 yes it's the same address we
recommend refusal on the following
grounds to change the user would allow
the milking to be separated from the
agricultural use this would allow its
sales as a private dwell approval of
this would not only set president but
severely damage the Integrity of MDC who
allowed this building purely for
agricultural years this would also
conflict with this unsubscribed for
development s2's Egypt right and eight
boundaries and Countryside 81 employment
H7 Agriculture and essential Works
accommodation if this application is
approved it will strategically undermine
those restrictions faced by Northern
District Council in first instance thank
you
thank you very much indeed Miss down
sorry we have the third public speaker
which is the agent Mr Stephen whale
again you probably heard D again you
have two minutes of public speaking from
the time you start speaking thank you
[Music]
suggestions information
that should be corrected
the Planning Commission was granted with
an Apple Store it included a bathroom it
included an office area
lines
[Music]
at the bathroom obviously needs plugins
the building was built in the correct
location
externally it has approved to find
information included internal report
it's never been empty it's been used as
an Apple store for some two years or so
I know the councils received legal
advice I don't know from whom but I
haven't seen it but whoever wrote it has
never been in the building
help otherwise obviously economy
reliable they're told by members
three cases have been mentioned are
grateful to councilor blooper or the
confirmation in answer his question the
quick save case the council is abandoned
you're like absolutely stage and wedding
they each the issue was the date of
substantial completion that's not the
issue of Escape in the same space there
was no funding permission at all in this
case there have been two
[Music]
to repeat this building has never been
left yet
as I say I've heard nothing and read
nothing to suggest that this application
philosophy reviews only more
thank you Mr well thank you
okay before I
um move to the recommendations at the
ending to add at this point in time Mr
Belcher
or would you like to wait for the debate
I I don't think so I I I I what I've
just heard from the agent
um
you know cases
um have
you can pick out one aspect of the case
if you want and absolutely right Sage
deals with
um substantial completion that's well
known that's its main point but it's the
it's the judgments that are important on
the principles of when a building is
constructed how do you determine what it
is and the cases of sage and well we'll
deal with that and there's case law
Evolution and Sage set out some um some
principles and well-win has developed
those principles and in the Whirlwind
case there was planning permission
there's actually a lot in a lot similar
to the Whirlwind case here
um very similar and as I said the um the
the barristers advice we have is is very
clear
and I've read through that advice very
carefully and I thoroughly agree with
his reasoning
um so the advice from your officers and
from an external lawyer instructed by
the council is very clear
um and just to repeat what I said
um the fact is the council has already
made a decision in issuing an
enforcement it's the the Barrister Mr
um Mr whale was right it's not taken
effect but the enforcement has been
issued that's the point
and it's only been deferred in taking
effect by uh an appeal
so the enforcement notice is active in
the sense that it's the subject of an
appeal that's the important Point
decision has been made by the council
therefore that the building is is a
dwelling an unlawful dwelling
thank you Mr quilch
um we now move the officer
recommendation is found on page 17 of
the report which is to refuse with
details found on page nine and section
nine my apologies page 29 do I have a
seconder
Thompson members uh past the chamber
over to yourselves thank you
um right I I actually have worked as an
enforcement officer in private sector
housing for over 30 years for London
Authority
um and I'm quite disappointed in the way
this case has been handled by officers
enforcement action should be a last
resort where there's
sort of no other means forward to
resolve issues and should be saved for
the worst offenders
um as far as I'm aware there's been no
opportunity for informal resolution of
this case
um I understand that
um the applicant was persuaded to put
extra insulation and extra facilities in
in to the building by the building
Control Officers I felt that they was
just doing everything right so
the fact that you're now saying that the
building was never built as approved I
would actually argue against and say
that in my view it was built as it
should have been and they did take
action to remove the extra walls that
they had been led to put up
I also feel that officers have actually
fettered their script their discretion
and engineered this so that they could
get their enforcement action in in order
to block this application
um and
I do think that the applicant has been
unfairly treated in this case the action
taken in my view is not proportionate
and I feel it has been
a biased decision
and I would actually
want to support the application for the
change of use Council label thank you
thank you very much any other members to
speak
thank you councilor Thompson and then
councilor stilts
um thank you chairman um
read the reason for refusal which was
contained in the offices
officers report to committee for the
application for the application that
went to Southeast because it wasn't
overturned it was a member overturn of
an officer recommendation which is that
the proposed development by virtue of
the scale design sighting of the
building within the open Countryside
would cause substantial harm to the
rural character in the area it's not
been adequately Justified that is to the
benefit of supporting an established
agricultural business so proposal is
therefore unacceptable and contrary to
policies
this one is 84 day one of the Woodland
District local development plan
I believe the officers had it right in
the first place I believe in bailand
Parish Council had it right in the first
place
this is a bungalow Apple Storage
requires Darkness low temperature
very high humidity in most in most
varieties of Apple this building doesn't
provide that it it never did
and it has been fitted out as a dwelling
and that's I'm sorry that's obviously to
me what it what it was meant to be when
it was constructed thank you thank you
thank you very much indeed um you can't
cast a stamp please
chairman
after I've had a couple of questions
are you going to stop us you know I'm
I'm going to be very um uh straight but
I don't I think as long as The Comebacks
are specific do any short ones um just
like me German
um can you I have confirmation or denial
that this the enforcement notice and the
process was speeded along due to certain
pressures by members
I'd like to I think that's important
I've been told that information if it's
right it's right if it's wrong it's
wrong you know I don't think I'm
breaching any legal things there or
whatever but I think it should be said
and it needs to be aired openly I'd also
like to
um
disagree slightly in the fact that this
building was built to spec it was built
to what the planning applications
approved I don't think I was on the
council name but I can't remember but
I've read a lot of information chairman
so I actually do struggle in the fact
that now this Council has issued an
enforcement notice to knock it down
without trying to actually
um to me it's a sledgehammer to crack a
nut and I cannot I cannot in my heart
recommend and agree with a demolishment
of a perfectly good building and I think
it's the failure of this Council to get
to this stage and I don't necessarily
I'm not sure how I'm going to vote so
please don't anybody say she's
predetermined I've read everything I've
listened to it and I think the
applicants have been forced into this I
don't know if they were going to come
for a dwell in two bedroom dwelling or
not but I think if they wanted you know
they shouldn't have been forced and
served an enforcement notice to demolish
how heartbreaking is that when you've
actually worked so hard and I know some
people in this chamber are going to say
oh she's been I don't know too hearty or
too soft and it's not a planning reason
or whatever we're human we've got a
climate emergency and we're going to
knock down a perfectly good building and
I feel that they have been pushed into a
corner and I think it's not I think it's
not right so the first question is I
think the only question is where and how
if members were pressurized given
officers pressures to actually serve
this enforcement and to knock it down
because I know cases in this District
that we're still waiting on and this
seems to have been rushed through so I
think that's for everybody's benefit
chairman and I'm sorry if it's
controversial but that's what it is no
thank you very much indeed this is why
the chamber exists Mr Johnson please
uh thank you chairman I have to admit um
I'm quite surprised at sort of hearing
that I would like to know
um if it's possible where this
information came from that officers were
pressured by members
um in the
um
in the three years I've been
at Malden
um I've never been pressured by members
um there may be cases where members have
felt that enforcement actions would be
taken
um fairly long-standing cases but never
have
um officers felt pressured
I'm just I'm actually quickly quite
taken aback by officers being pressured
in this particular case
um
officers do not move straight to
um uh serving an enforcement notice
unless there is a clear and present sort
of evidence of of of of significant harm
you know especially when it concerns
immunity
um
that's the general principle under which
under which we operate in any case I've
been enforcement action there's normally
a communication
with the alleged contravena in terms of
what the unauthorized development with
and an opportunity given for the alleged
contravena to make good the development
so that would have taken place yeah
um it's it's it's it's as I said it's
never really a case where a notice is
just served and that did not happen in
this in this particular case so officers
were not pressured
um in any way whatsoever there was no
outside influence obviously the followed
due process
um and that's the facts of this
particular matter so there's no
impropriety otherwise in terms of how
this enforcement actually had been
expedited I don't really want to the the
issue here is not for us to be
discussing the enforcement action I just
wanted to get clarification of that the
issue is here is about the planning
application and the issues the officers
have in terms of the application which
has been applied for which we're seeking
to a determination on today thank you
chairman thank you indeed Mr Johnson
thank you thank you chair can I get a
better understanding please on the um I
know we've just heard that the
enforcement isn't relevant but it really
so is because I haven't really grasped
how
we as a council have agreed a building
and ticked all the boxes when it was
built and yet now we're saying it's not
what should have been built and maybe
I've just misunderstood the sequence of
events there could somebody explain that
please thank you
the fact is it wasn't built to
specification uh the externally it was
but internally it wasn't
now again this comes back to the
Whirlwind case and this particularly the
Whirlwind case internal layout on the
on the construction of a building is
relevant in determining its character so
although it was
um I understand it was constructed in
accordance with the planning permission
externally
that was not the case internally and the
photographs show things that were were
done in their subdivisions that were not
compatible with the approved plans
um as far as the planning permission was
concerned I think that's right isn't it
yeah
um so it's not true that it was built
according to specification
okay no
thanks chairman just as a as a follow-up
to that I mean in the in the uh
the the representation of support
um for the for the case it was stated
that the that the owner was persuaded by
building control to put insulation is
that is not the role of building control
uh to be persuading Developers
what what what building control do is
they guide
um the uh uh any builder in terms of the
building regulations relevant to the
building which they are building that's
the purpose of it thank you chairman
thank you very much indeed Mr Johnson
Casa Jennings please
and I really hate to be the one to ask
the obvious but why wasn't the changes
internally noticed by the planning
department after their many visits and
then asked for the applicants to change
those things to make them more suitable
for an Agricultural interior
surely there would be no
case
thus far I think you miss her now please
thank you so planning wouldn't carry out
a site visit um until a planned
outpatient submitted and enforcement is
reactive rather than proactive and
because the development is being carried
out as it has there is no there's no
longer a planning permission to fall
back on so even if you removed
everything internally and this appeared
as an agricultural building there is no
planning permission in place so they
would still need to apply
you certainly can thank you
I think we have a bit of a problem in
the fact that
you don't visit a planning application
to begin with and it only gets to an
enforcement stage to realize that there
are internal problems and by that point
the applicant really doesn't have any
chance of changing them for the better
and for their business am I right
Mr Welch yeah I mean let's understand
the process here a bit a planning
application is put in by somebody with
their plans
with their plans not the council's plans
planning permission is granted and one
of the conditions is that you will
construct in accordance with the
approved plans those are not the
council's plans those are the applicants
plans that may be modified during the
application process but ultimately they
are approved as the applicant's plans
now it's the responsibility at law
we may not like this but it is the
responsibility at law for that planning
permission to be built that that
development to be built out in
accordance strictly
with the planning permission now I don't
know when the visits from it I have to
say I I don't know I wasn't involved in
that but whether there were visits early
on or not that's not the point the point
is
that a building has to be built out in
accordance with the planning permission
and if it's not it can be treated as not
built as per their planning permission
councilor Passenger please
thank you chair um just sort of again as
a point of clarity really for me so the
first stage the building was built but
it wasn't built to the planning
permission that's was that so that has
now gone to appeal because there's an
enforcement notice sir is that correct
so we are this evening discussing the
the other part of the planning which is
the change of use is that correct so
should this Council be in mind to refuse
or or Grant
nothing really will happen until we get
the appeal and if the appeal is approved
can it then come back
if if members decide to approve this
application that will bring an end to
the process of the appeal the
enforcement notice will fall
because planning permission already
exists
granted by the very Authority that
served the enforcement notice
and and so
um
the only
because it will be several months I
would think before we get a decision
letter from the Planner inspectorate on
whether they agree with the district
council's case or they agree with the
applicant's case and an inspector who
knows nothing about this case will have
to make that decision was it built in
was it built as a dwelling was it built
as an agricultural Bond if it was built
if he comes and decides it was built as
uh in accordance with the planning
permission and it's an agricultural
building
then
um a change of use application could be
made but if members Grant the change of
use that if you think about it that
brings to an end
the enforcement notice process so on one
hand the council's made a decision
um that it's not
an agricultural building and then the
council makes a decision via this
process that it is because you can only
make a change of use on an authorized
building and we are saying via the the
council is saying by the enforcement
notice process
that it isn't an authorized building
does that make sense
may I come back yeah so would it not
possibly have been better to have waited
for the appeal decision before we were
in this position
to be fair to the applicants they put in
their planning application in January
this year February this year so there
their planning application pre-dates
the enforcement notice which was served
in July July
um yeah at the end of July
um so
the council now is in a position where
it has to determine the planning
application now this is an interesting
point here because under Section 70 c of
the Town and Country planning Act 1990.
if someone puts in a planning
application say say the applicants are
putting the planning at this planning
application that you're considering
today
after the enforcement notice have been
issued then the council has a discretion
under statute not to determine that
application until the inquiry goes
through but because the application was
put in prior to the service of the
enforcement notice the district council
can't rely on Section 70c to decline to
determine the application in other words
the council hasn't a legitimate in the
sense it it's an application the council
has to valid had to validate and
consider
before it
so just just play Devil's Advocate
really so if we if we were inclined to
refuse and this the other part of the
application still went to the appeal and
the inspector said that they granted
um the application how would that work
does one out weigh the other no if if
you grant the planning application today
am I understanding is that is the end of
the matter uh you you've granted a
change of use what you're saying
therefore is it is you've made the
decision
that it is a dwelling house
and that you're sorry that it is an
agricultural building and that you're
granting a change of use to it becoming
a dwelling house
okay so that will be the end of the
matter if you've granted planning
permission say we refused would the
appeal still take place and if the
appeal Was Won it would then be deemed a
a agricultural building and then that
could come back yeah what would happen
if you refused the application today the
I'm sure the applicants will continue
their appeal it's obviously in their
interest to continue their appeal and an
inspector would have to decide who was
right are the applicants right
um is is the council right
um if the inspector says the applicants
are right
and it is an agricultural building then
they could put in another application
for a change of use because they would
then have the benefit of the inspector's
decision that says it is an agricultural
Building Council you're wrong on that
point
um it is a building agricultural
building that would legitimize therefore
in my view an application for a change
of use then I wouldn't be here giving
you the advice that I'm giving now we
wouldn't be relying on the Whirlwind
case or anything like that
okay I'm good points council with him
please
thank you
um sorry I'm having a little bit of
trouble getting my head around these I'm
finding it very confusing
um
the building is meant to be there yes
it's the building was okay the the
planning permission was approved
originally it's for the external of the
building
and then were they not asked to remove
the internal petitions which they then
did so where I I'm a little bit lost no
it's not the building shouldn't be there
that's the point the building should not
be there at planning law according to
the assessment of the district council
because it was built as a dwelling house
without planning permission
okay that's the point of the well-wing
case
right but were they not sorry were they
not asked to remove those petitions and
they did so that is correct as I
understand it's some remedial Works were
done however once the building has been
built that is what it is you can't then
subsequently
change the building once you've
completed it
so the building was substantially
complete and then changes were taken
place changes took place to to remedy
some of the problems
but that doesn't change that it was
built as a dwelling house if you see
what I mean sorry just so on
yeah I think that's largely correct
ified without all
sorry with
the the the the the issue that we as a
local Planet Authority have is the fact
that this was applied for a change of
view so we've made all this argument to
say you can't apply for a change of use
because the agricultural building had
never existed yeah right yeah they may
have built the frame but when you look
at the building
you know it's it you know it's almost
like one of these old warehouses you
know and now they're residential you
know that sort of thing yeah it's it's
effectively a resident a residential
building
this is not the application that should
have been submitted yep right now there
was a point in had they submitted an
application for a retrospective dwelling
house yeah so there may be cases where
people will carry out unauthorized
development
um now it'd been unauthorized doesn't
necessarily mean it's illegal and I do
remember making this point another
committee and asked this question a few
weeks ago uh it doesn't make it illegal
but it's unauthorized
but one has the opportunity to apply for
planning permission but that's an
admission that okay we've built this it
hasn't got planning permission but now
we seek plan permission yep
the only thing with that is that you may
get applied information because we may
say yeah it's okay it's fine but then
you may not get planning permission
because we may say it's it's
unacceptable
so in in a case so if there was a
retrospective application your one is
running the risk because we could say
well you know our policies say dwellings
are unacceptable outside the settlement
boundary blah blah blah that that sort
of thing so there is a risk in terms of
that yeah so this is a position which is
here we are not dealing with an
application for retrospective
application
and like I said but the retrospection
application is the admission that this
is unauthorized development yeah
so it's so it's really totally
irrelevant as to what the external of
the building is because that's
because of what's going on inside what
what sorry what I'm trying to make is I
fail to see the reason to to demolish
the building if
if it's already got permission to be
there sorry that's just me being I just
can't get my head around that music I'll
come back Mr Johnson one more time thank
you yeah
um
where there is a failure to comply with
the council's
suggestions of how to remedy the breach
yeah yeah then what's left with the
council is that then we will serve an
enforcement notice yeah now we serve an
enforcement notice the end product of
the enforcement notice is that the
breach must be remedied
sometimes that breach
something that sometimes we're
constrained by planning law yeah
so in Plano we can't say then you it can
then go back to
whatever it was meant to be yeah because
it was never like that yeah
right it was never like that had it been
built like that and it's been used for a
few years and all of a sudden it became
a dwelling we could say you've got to
put it back to a dwelling yeah what
we're saying and this is the reason just
just to go back to the uh let's say
quick fit myself the the quick save case
yeah initially the discussion was around
the quick save case because there were
discussions on how long
had or whether any agricultural use had
taken place so we said well okay well
maybe if I I don't want to sound
flippant I know nothing about apple
storage or you know or cultivation or
anything like that but they were growing
a few apples and what have you and they
did this for a few months people would
say well hang on that doesn't Institute
it as a formal use you only did it for
one season or something like that you
can't then just say build it okay do for
one season and then we'll apply for
change abuse yeah that is not a material
implementation of the planning
permission yeah so we're not dealing
with that so the thing is I mean part of
the remedy could have been say okay well
you have to submit maybe an application
for a retrospective application
but then that's that's an admission that
there's unauthorized development yeah if
one fails to do that then we'll say well
we have no choice but to do yeah if an
enforcement notice says that it must be
demolished it doesn't necessarily mean
that you know we're going to send around
the demolition companies next day there
are still discussions and negotiations
that that may come on if we see that
there is a willingness
to actually try and comply and go
through due process the local Authority
is not unreasonable in that respect and
I've worked in a number of authorities
where that approach has been taken thank
you thank you very much indeed Mr
Johnson
Miss Hannah wants to comment as well
please thank you and just to clarify I
think there's been a lot of discussion
about why we haven't advised for a
retrospective application and just to
highlight the validation stage an
invalid letter went out to the applicant
to say from the information submitted it
appears that the building has not been
been put into use for agricultural
purposes therefore the application is
not for a change of use but for the
provision of a two-bedroom Bungalow the
applicant
um was adamant that you know that there
hadn't been um that the youth had was
Agricultural and decided to proceed on
the basis of the application as
submitted but as officers we gave that
advice that our feeling was it should be
a retrospective application so I just
wanted to clarify that point Thank You
councilor siddle please
thank you chair I first of all would
like to uh Express how disappointed I am
in terms of uh the it being raised at
officers would be put under pressure at
all I found that very questionable we
are one team at this or that this
Council and we work as one team and the
thought that someone would put pressure
on an officer is not acceptable and does
not happen at this Council and is not
acceptable at this Council
we need to ensure that we act
accordingly I am not disappointed that
this enforcement case was raised in July
because there was a breach of the
planning and officers acted accordingly
and professionally and in the right way
and in saying that this building is
illegal when they did that that is true
it has not been built to its
specification by any stretch of the
imagination is it an Apple store it is
not an Apple Store an Apple Store does
not have wooden floors which needs
protected by when agricultural equipment
are put on them
as councilor Thompson said this breaches
so many planning policies yeah it's it's
questionable that that we're even here
really because it cannot in any by
stretch of imagination meet planning
regulations so you know this is a house
the interesting is in terms of some of
the things that we've heard tonight from
the people who want us to approve this
is they're expressing that this is
crucial to the applicant's business
but they want it to be a domestic
dwelling
that is completely incongruous
so if they want it to be crucial to
their apple business they should have
built an Apple Store not a domestic
building so we need to ensure we refuse
this application because the precedent
it would be set for this Council and for
this dictatory is extremely dangerous
thank you thank you Council Seattle
councilor Stevens please
oh thank you but my point has already
been raised thanks thank you Council
Stevens councilor stem please
yeah thank you not going to get any Tit
for Tat but I was actually given that
information that's why I raised it
um I'd like to go to page 29 which is
the reason for refusal and it says based
on the information submitted and
available to the council and have in
regard to the design appearance layout
character and the purpose of the
application building whatever
everybody's read it and if you go to
page 24 6.11 it says planning permission
has previously been granted for the
construction of an Apple Storage Barn at
site and the number of chairman it is
acknowledged that the exterior of the
building has been constructed largely in
accordance with the previous approved
plans there are now also additional
Windows being proposed as part of this
application however in order to address
whether and everybody can read it so
what I've actually got a bit of
confusion it says that it's been built
in accordance or largely in accordance
and then it says in the reason for
refusal the appearance layout character
it hasn't German so what has it has it
been or hasn't it been thank you chair
thank you any comments
thank you so the references to design
appearance layout and character within
the reason refusal refers back to the
sage case law that which actually talks
about how the internal of the building
and its appearance internally can
influence on the youth so that's why the
word in in the reason for refusal has
been used but of course it's in members
gifts if they say fit to Amendment for
refusal thank you
we're really we're actually saying the
council's doing interpretation of it is
this we could all go and we think the
interpretation of the building could be
that where is the actual law that the
council makes that decision you quoted
and please forgive me Mr Clutch because
I've lost a bit section whatever it was
you said section 7c of the Town and
Country planning act gives the plan in
authorities the power to decline to
determine applications
um where there is an active notice you
did actually say so I'll give you you
know thank you very much for saying it
I've put but it does it also give the
council power not to determine it or to
give the advice not to determine it
because you've said it is is there
anything in that law that says that
legal law of reference let me I'm
getting interest the section whatever it
is bear with me chairman and members
I've just said it which one was it 70c
Town and Country planet is anything in
there that says that the opposite can be
done
thank you and I won't speak again yeah I
I think there may be some confusion
um here about section six are you I
raised section 70c just to answer I
think councilor Bassinger's question
um about you know what which one trumps
the inspector's decision or the the
decision tonight
um on what you do with this planning
application what I was simply trying to
say is
if there had been if this application
had been put in post the service of the
enforcement notice then the council has
the discretion under Section 70 c not to
determine the application simply because
of this matter the councilor Basinger
raised this problem but because
the planning application was put in
um earlier than the service of the
enforcement is the council cannot use it
cannot come to you and say members we're
going to rely on Section 7270c
um you don't have to determine this
application so that that's the context
in which I use section 70 c
thank you
Castle Morley please
thank you chair my question's already
been answered about the internal rules
thank you very much thank you very much
councilor Paula spenceley please
write out the um
the email that was sent the
correspondence that was sent with regard
to you advising the applicant that they
should put in a retrospective
application at that point because to me
a lot of this seems to hinge on that
technicality that we're looking at it as
a change of use
um rather than as retrospective now I
have to question why the applicant would
have refused to do that when that was
the advice given and I want to cast no
aspersions whatsoever but it wouldn't be
seemly
I suspect to say at that point that it
was a retrospective application
and that is what concerns me about the
Integrity of this Council going forward
I'd like to know
what the position would be if that
appeal the enforcement didn't succeed
would the applicant then be able to
apply for a retrospective permission if
they changed their mind on that can you
talk me around that
I don't think there's if if the so if
you're saying the appeal succeeds in
other words the enforcement is squashed
yes if the enforcement is quashed then
they don't they don't need a
retrospective planning application
because the inspector would agree with
the applicants that it's an agricultural
building so it therefore would be an
application for change of use which is
what you've got in front of you okay
thank you thank you Council Thompson
please
absolutely fine thank you
um
there's been a lot of talk chairman
about you know whether it's built to
spec or not and the external appearance
really is largely in accordance
but that still doesn't make it an Apple
Store as has been very well pointed out
there has to be a certain amount of
Caveat Emptor here if you want a
building to store apples it's the
African's job
to pick a plan for a building that's
good for storing apples
if they choose not to if they choose to
build a pick a design that's better for
storing people I can't see that it's
actually the local plumbing Authority's
job to point out that well that's not
actually what you really want
because this is what we last for and the
decision is made on what you've asked
for but it plainly isn't suitable
and making it a dwelling
giving change of views to a dwelling
again that doesn't help the business in
any way as I've read out from the
previous recommended reasons for refusal
it's still well outside lots of policies
difficult running some Countryside of
our policies
yeah I'm just not happy it's
the to them and I just can't cannot see
that it was ever intended to be anything
else thank you Mr Johnson
thanks chairman just a small matter of
clarity again when when when a
development is implemented it's
implemented it's in in its entirety one
cannot just build a shell
and kit out the internals differently
and the development having been
implemented it's it's a development it's
in his entirety which means how it was
approved the plans as was pointed out by
my colleague
um being carried out that's a standard
condition we put on all planning
permissions normally condition two
development should be carried out in
accordance with the approved plans yep
but also in terms of its use and what
one would perceive as the building to be
and I do think just to pick up a line
from um uh a member that was quoted at
the southeast committee if it sort of
uh sounds a bit funny looked like a
chicken you know that sort of thing yeah
that's effectively what we're actually
dealing with because I know that that
was a point that that that you had
raised but just to clarify that
implementation of the development is in
its entirety not just a part of it thank
you chairman thank you very much
I think people have spoken a lot I just
need to move forward thank you very much
uh councilor fluke please thank you
Council
thank you Mr chairman I think obviously
it's quite a complicated situation and
it's been made more complicated by the
process has been followed by the
applicant that wouldn't necessarily
conform to the normal order of
convention now uh just for clarity I
mean as I'm saying this is we have an
application in front of us for a change
of use
the officers have actually recommended
refusal based upon the change of use and
if members were to Grant permission for
it then the application for it to be a
house will never been determined
because that is the way the process will
work so in in essence what we'll have
done would have created this situation
where we've just said build a house
because there are the the officers
cannot determine it against anything
other than the requests that's been
presented I mean that's something
perhaps the officers could comment on
that
then you're coming to make it
not more of a statement yeah okay
so no response thank you so we moved to
Casa fluka
thank you chairman um we've before I go
on to what I was going to say can I just
say chairman for the benefit of people
that are trolling me at the moment that
I uh I met with the monitoring officer
today and I explained my relationship
with the applicants and confirm the fact
that I'd actually attended a wedding
along with lots of other members as well
and uh having explained my relationship
in full the monitoring office and I both
agreed that on the information I gave
him that there was no close Association
which allows me to take part in this
debate tonight so there's a couple of
things here chairman and in many ways it
we seem to be in the same position now
as where we were at the southeast area
planning committee so I'm sorry to
Lumber that on you and
you know it all goes back to this
members application to refer to
committees you know one wonders whether
or not this really is a good idea this
evening although I think in general it
is but chairman we we have to make sure
we make this decision absolutely we get
it right and um and it's interesting
that when Mr quilts referred to this uh
appeal against it against against
enforcement important enforcement he did
actually say well we will know then if
we've got this right by the result of
the appeal now we know that this
committee doesn't always get it right
because I'd refer you all to Malden Road
uh wooden Mortimer where we are all
facing a big cost decision against us
I'll leave you all to re listen to that
tape again draw your own conclusions but
chairman this all hinges around
is this an Apple store or not an Apple
store and what concerns me enormously is
is that we've had a barrister come to
this meeting tonight on behalf of the
applicant who is content and contrary to
the officers view that this is an Apple
Store
uh I hear Mr quelch's argument and the
planning officers argument that say it's
not an Apple Store
so we we have this argument and we
unders we all understand this is how
things proceed through the courts and
and everybody's got views on all of this
but German rather than leave this
Council exposed which I suspect will be
a rather expensive appeal
and through you to the monitoring
officer am I right in
thinking chairman
if we were to defer this decision until
the planning inspector had determined
the appeal against enforcement
then that would not leave this planning
Authority exposed and then from that
point onwards we would know we would
know whether or not this is an Apple
store or not there's almost certainly
going to be a public inquiry and I do
hope members that feel passionate either
for this or not attend and give the
members view it will also give the local
planning Authority Mr quelch and anybody
else who he instructs to debate this in
the presence of the pounding inspector
and Mr whale and they can both put their
cases forward and pins can actually make
this the first part of this decision on
behalf of us now on behalf of the local
planning author so chairman if Mr quelch
agrees that that's possible then I would
propose that we defer until the appeal
against enforcement is dealt with thank
you chair thank you
honestly that's a a very interesting
um
suggestion at the moment it's not a I
appreciate it's not a motion at the
moment
um right
um I think that's an unusual proposal
but I don't think it's unlawful the
reason the reason I say this is for
these reasons is that the purpose you
have to ask yourself what is the purpose
of deferring an application to determine
a planning application and it's normally
because you want to do a site visit or
because you need more information and
until you have that information you
don't think you can make a decision
now
um I suppose you're in the situation
here where you would like confidence as
to whether this is an agricultural
building or whether this is a dwelling
house who's right is it the applicants
is it the District Council
um
that decision as councilor fluke has
already said will be made at a
forthcoming planning inquiry and I don't
know when that will be yet these things
do take several months
um now
my view would be that is a lawful
decision the only Rider to that is the
applicants could appeal
could appeal to the inspector for
non-determination but that's okay
because because that will obviously take
a long time as well
to get to the inspectorate so in fact
what will probably happen is they will
probably conjoin the two the enforcement
notice appeal and what's called the
section 78 appeal if the applicants
decide to appeal to the inspector for
the council not determining the
application within the statutory period
because obviously we're out well outside
the statutory
uh I so move
um thank you we need to move on to
councilor Haywood at the second Council
flew to this motion
no it's not the emotion has not been
seconded so we need to move to councilor
Thompson please
make a point
just bear with us a second members Mr
Johnson yeah thank you chairman just
just regarding the appeal um the
the the Council on the 31st of July
received a start letter from pins
regarding the appeal and the appealers
to be heard by a way of public inquiry
so
what the
um what the letter says which might be
just useful and anyways Kyla was
following on from Council fluka's
suggestion although not not sort of held
any evidence supporting a claim for use
has to show a continuous period of use
for the relevant four or ten year period
the onus of proof is on an appellant
the test to be achieved is on the
balance of probability
just sort of just sort of make that
clear
thank you very much indeed just to be
clear as well the motion that was levied
by Council fluke was not seconded so we
are going to take that forward thank you
we go to councilor Thompson please
actually I wanted to come back before
and rather overtaken by events now but I
just want
just wanted Johnson I wasn't at all
suggesting that I disagreed with his
advice about the thing being done in
completeness only that it isn't planning
office's job to point out that the
building you want to be an Apple Store
might not be a very good Apple Store
that's the applicant's problem
thank you thank you very much if you
want to build an Apple store and design
it with French windows that doesn't make
it a good Apple Store
thank you and councilor Haywood is the
final name I have on my list thank you
that's
um really what I wanted to do actually
just give a little bit of a history of
the site from someone who actually lives
I'm a mailing Council and obviously
lived within the area of um
that you have members please thank you
sorry sorry um yeah we've obviously
within the area so obviously got a
little bit of add my bit of history for
the site going back to the original site
which obviously it's showing on there as
well there was actually before this
Apple Barn was actually
um proposed and accepted there was a
proposed detached dwelling on the site
where the Apple Barn is now this was
actually a withdrawn one now this this
leaves me in the consideration in 2018
the cons the construction of the Apple
bomb was approved and numerous
applications for changes of conditions
and fenestration followed so that's
windows and everything was changed and
they were all approved all the way
through no problem with that
um as far as I'm aware the building has
never been used for its purpose as an
Apple Barn obviously we've heard
differently tonight but as far as that
is my
um sight on it and and I always do I'm
beginning to believe now this was
intended to be a residential building
that was proposed in 2017 and we've
drawn because there was an original
building they were wanted and then they
changed their mind and then went through
an apple bomb
um obviously on this site as well it's a
bit of a confusing sight and obviously
living within the area it's a big plot
of land I'm not sure if everyone is
aware that there is also another
application to anyone stroke 0062a
within the whole plot of the land which
was approved in 21 to allow a
residential work lived well into the to
be built in the ground in front of the
Apple bomb
this was the was this was an officer's
recommendation to refuse and was passed
at a planning meeting
the site is outside obviously the
mainland settlement boundary and if we
allow the barn to be changed to a
residential dwelling that would give two
dwellings within this plot
this leads me to go to the cough sites
now the call for sites this plot is also
the front half of it this block has been
added a suggestion under May 10 for a
proposed site for eight dwellings
so I propose that The Apple Barn as we
feel this is but the office's
recommendation as it has never been used
for its intensity its entending purposes
and we'll add two dwellings within the
whole plot which will potentially lead
to more being added in the future
thank you we have already had this
proposal that's been second but thank
you very much for your contribution uh
Council driver please
yeah it seems to me that the
uh the whole case injures on whether
hinges or whether this really is an
Apple Barn or not and I find it very
hard to see how what has been presented
to us is actually an Apple Barn
I find that very difficult to understand
and my understanding of the storage of
fruit is that you need a cool space in
order to store fruit for any length of
time
are having read uh or all the material
that goes along with it I don't see any
evidence that over any period of time
apart from maybe a box or something or
other apples have genuinely been stored
within this Apple Barn and therefore it
does pose the question as to why you
would build an Apple Barn which isn't an
Apple Barn unless actually you have an
alternative use in mind and I it just in
my view that actually this has been this
has been done with an alternative use in
mind
um so I would I would vote to refuse
this application yeah we have thank you
Mr Casa driver we'll have the vote very
shortly um just one comment from a bit
of a fruit you do have areas of um
buildings that aren't warm to ripen
product and there's no Direct in my
experience
um others would have to raise an
interest just it's a personal interest
from working for a fruit grown company
that there are different structures and
different shapes and different sizes of
all different fruit
preparation ripening and storage
buildings it's just a personal comment
from myself
members is anybody who hasn't spoken
wished to speak on this issue
okay members I think everybody's had
we've had a very robust a very detailed
um debate we have a recommendation to
refuse which has been seconded uh
members how do you wish to proceed to
this vote do you wish to have a recorded
vote thank you very much mindful of my
motion and likely costs is that motion
second did counselor seconded by
councilor stamp Tara
um we can therefore go to a recorded
vote
um
so we'll be calling um four for the
refusal or against
to approve that's my understanding it's
four if you accept the recommendation
reviews and against if you don't accept
the recommendations very clear all
members understand that nice and clear
right okay we'll say it first so if you
the recommendation is to refuse so if
you're for the refusal it's four
if you're against the refusal to try to
approve it's against
okay anybody not clear it's very
important and I've got it twisted in the
past so I know how complicated it can be
okay Tara over to you thank you
four
against
Jennings four
the lake
four
against
councilman Miller abstain
some Molly
against
Council meal four
Council Shaughnessy abstain
for
[Music]
normal
okay thank you for that
thank you very much thank you sir
inexpensively four
perhaps the coldest night sleep four
Council system
against
the Stevens
four
against
Swindle four
cancer Thompson
four
okay
thank you members chairman the results
of that are 14 4 8 against and two
extensions thank you Jenna thank you
very much in detail there for the
recommendation to refuse is carried
members we move on to agenda item six
which is any other items of business
that the chairman decides the origin I
have had a request from councilor fluka
to table a small uh item about appeals
um you know I don't know how it managed
to drop off the agenda but it certainly
has done in the last couple of years but
we often used to report the uh the
result of appeals that applied to
certain committees uh and I think that
there's much to be learned from the
appeal decision Malden Road wooden
mortar and what went on there chairman
um maybe it's something that you could
take back to committee service to see if
it's something that we could
reinvigorate thank you yeah thank you
very much indeed councilor fluka yep
I'll certainly do that
you certainly can
just my understanding of how this may be
taken forward what sort of form were you
previously used and what you would be
expecting to be reported chairman I'll
I'll um refer the officer back to
committee services and I'm sure that
they can look at previous meetings and
see exactly how we did this and it was
very very informative and I'm more than
happy to meet with the officer and to to
speak about other issues as well I think
that's the most amical solution so thank
you very much indeed thank you Mr
Johnson yeah thank you so members we
moved to agenda item seven now after
recent local government events I think
we need to pay pay heed to this uh the
closure of the meeting uh thank you for
your contributions this evening greatly
for a very informed debate I now draw
the meeting to a close at
20 51 PM as the meeting is now closed
members are advised not to enter into
any further discussions and please leave
the meeting via the exit door behind the
top table bearing in mind social
distancing or the front there and all
microphones need to be turned off thank
you members